zendaya has a big fan in her euphoria
co-star Jacob oh lordy it's crazy the 22
year old actor is singing her praises in
the new issue of GQ Australia though the
two were spotted vacationing in Greece
back in August and just recently in
Australia oh lordy shot down any dating
rumors I wouldn't want you to say
something you might regret telling GQ
quote zendaya is an amazing creative you
know she is super dope to work with
she's an incredible artist and a very
caring person to all of us adding quote
she's like my sister jacob spoke to ET
in october where he revealed what it's
been like watching the success of
euphoria
I mean euphoria is such a hit I mean
renewed for a second season before the
first season have really got into the
meat of it have you embraced that yet is
it still a bit surreal to you how much
people love this series I mean it kind
of feels like it's none of my business
to me come on you're one of the leads on
the show you know we made it and then we
give it to everybody and then let them
have it it's exciting it's really cool
I'm glad that while talking with ET
ahead of the shows premiere zendaya
also pointed to the show cast as the
reason for its success this show I
watched the first episode it is such a
departure for you what did you learn
about yourself making this and really
tackling this type of subject matter I
just I don't know I learned a lot I
think I I think we all in this cast
about to push ourselves and be
vulnerable and and it's been hard and
there's been fun days and there's been
really tough days but I'm so lucky to be
working with the people that I'm working
with I'm so thankful for the warm
I think safe space that we've created
said to be able to go to those places
and and yeah I'm just you know proud of
it
[Music]